ja und dann 26 stunden später sind wir
wieder von bord gegangen wieder rauf
aufs flugzeug weg zu dieser zu tun der
transportmaschine mit der wir auch hin
gezogen sind und machen müsste langsam
bereit für den katapultstart da ist ja
die beschleunigung von null auf fast 200
stundenkilometern innerhalb weniger
sekunden
man sitzt rückwärts also man fliegt
wieder rückwärts setzt sich dahin muss
ich sehr sehr gut anschnallen bekommt
noch ein paar anweisungen einweisungen
wie man sich genau zu bewegen hatte und
dann schreien die das ist hier beginnt
wenige sekunden später putzen riesigen
schlag und man wird wirklich
abgeschossen und ist dann in der luft
und schwebt quasi liegt frei macht schon
mit dem körper einiges an endorphin
wieder in 1 1 geschossen werden